okay so the iPhone 13 and 14 Pros has a  3X telephoto camera right so the  absolute Max that you can zoom in on  this phone is 15x total Zoom it looks  okay but Apple's definitely betting you  won't really want to do much more than  that so then you've got Samsung and the  space zoom in their Ultra phones so this  is the Galaxy s22 Ultra with two  telephoto cameras so you can zoom to 3x  10x 30X or go straight to 100x now I  don't know what you're going to do with  this sort of reach but it is  surprisingly stable and once you snap  the photo and then go to look at it it  processes and snaps into focus and you  get a lot of usable detail I mean it's  not a great shot by any means but  Samsung is hoping you'll find this  useful I personally hardly ever use  space Zoom but the truth is they keep  leveling it up every year the first  version of this two years ago was pretty  bad but here we are tax and body who  does Zoom all the way in on their phone